in den letzten wochen meine damen und
herren wurde gestrickt was das zeug hält
um diese dossiers zu produzieren
die selbst gestrickten mützen sind das
neue symbol der weltweiten
frauenbewegung die seit der wahl von
donald trump neu an fahrt gewonnen hat
doch welche ideen befeuern die seefahrt
und wohin soll es überhaupt gehen
darüber rede ich jetzt mit laurie penny
einer der wichtigsten stimmen des neuen
feminismus loipen ist aktivistin und
journalistin unter anderem beim guardian
und new statesman und sie ist
buchautorin
sie sagt sie - muss ist viel mehr als
eine frauenrechtsbewegung uns die
nächste revolution wird feministisch
sein kalorie penny haben sie selber auch
gestrickt ich kann überhaupt nicht
stricken aber jemand gab mir einen kuss
ii hat am frauen marsch in washington an
dem ich glücklicherweise teilnehmen
konnte
eine mütze die eine mutter gestrickt
hatte war übrig und die frauen sagten du
hast keinen im sie diese waren sie hat
sind sehr hässlich aber das ist wohl der
punkte so meiner war doch eigentlich
ganz schwere müsse sie zu s aus sie sind
für mich die erste der sie gut steht ein
wunder
vielleicht war eine echte feministin
dann post gut und das ist eindeutig die
neue definition einer wahren feministin
sieht gut aus in einem posiert eine sehr
lustige definition seit der wahl von
donald trump sind ja auf der ganzen welt
women's marge ist im gang
alleine am 21 januar gingen 2,5
millionen menschen auf die straße
sind wir mitten in der feministischen
revolution die sie aufkündigen frau
penny
sicher ist es aufregend zu sehen wie
sich frauen und ihre verbündeten auf der
ganzen welt mobilisieren und auf die
straße gehen es ist ein symbolischer
moment doch der grund warum sich so
viele menschen auf diese weise gehör
verschaffen ist die tatsache dass wir in
vielerlei hinsicht rückschritte
bereits in den ersten wochen von donald
trumps amtsantritt wurden in den usa und
anderswo auf der welt die abtreibungs
rechte eingeschränkt es gab
zurückweisungen von einwanderern wodurch
viele familien auseinandergerissen
wurden auch zahlreiche frauen wurden von
der polizei und vom start ins visier
genommen und ausgeschafft oder mit der
ausschaffung bedruckt es ist keine
schöne zeit für die weltweite
frauenbewegung
es wird viel energie hineingesteckt aber
diese gilt vor allem für
abwehrstrategien drauf das ist aufregend
aber nicht unbedingt positiv positiv
könnte man sagen die frauenbewegung die
ja ein stück weit fast schon im post
feministischen koma dahin geschlummert
hat brauchte einen gemeinsamen verein
wieder nun die frauenbewegung ist in den
letzten zehn jahren wirklich stärker
geworden
es ist holz erleben wie auf eine neue
art über feminismus diskutiert wird
sei es im internet oder in communitys in
den letzten fünf sechs jahren habe ich
bücher geschrieben und bin viel gereist
dabei hatte ich das glück überall auf
der welt frauen zu begegnen auch sehr
jungen die den feminismus neu entdeckt
haben und sagen dass noch sehr viel zu
tun ist
vier dieser frauen gehen jetzt auf die
straße aber wir engagieren uns schon
eine ganze weile was empörend ist die
gleichen die uns feministinnen seit
jahren angreifen schikanieren und uns
todesdrohungen schicken kommen nun
überall auf der welt an die macht die
möchte ich ein zu rufen wir haben euch
doch vor diesen typen gewarnt und nun
haben sie an einfluss gewonnen
doch erst jetzt wo es fast zu spät ist
horch die welt plötzlich auf etwas was
mich sehr interessiert ist das ja die
verschiedenen populistischen strömungen
die eben weltweit an fahrt gewinnen sie
haben es gerade erwähnt teilen sozusagen
ein nationalistisches gedankengut ein
fremdenfeindliches gedankengut sehr oft
auch und einen anti elitäres gedankengut
und jetzt kommt hinzu noch
oft sexistisches gedankengut wie kommst
du diese verquickung was habt ihr
sexismus eigentlich politisch sozusagen
oder auf dem politischen feld zu suchen
nun etwas haben diese neuen bewegungen
gemeinsam die anhänger sind vor allem
männlich und meistens weiß und im
zentrum steht die verletzung des
maskulinen weißen stolz diese männer
sind felsenfest überzeugt davon dass die
welt ihnen schwerstes unrecht zugefügt
hat man hat ihnen den von der natur
zugedachten platz in der hierarchie
geraubt deshalb tun sie alles um unsere
errungenschaften zu zerstören
es gibt tatsächlich auch einen
antisemitismus aber viele haben eine
falsche vorstellung davon was and is
muss ist sie haben den eindruck
antirassismus feminismus und lgb
bewegungen sein elitäres strömungen
doch das stimmt nicht die anhänger
kommen aus allen gesellschaftsschichten
und jene die nur dank weit rechts
stehende papierbogen an der macht sind
gehören zu den elitärsten menschen die
man sich vorstellen kann
donald trump oder banker wie der brite
nigel farage das sind reiche weiße
männer sie sind ganz und gar nicht aus
der unterdrückten unterschicht stimme
ich ihnen völlig zu aber mich
interessiert immer noch dieser punkt
warum der sexismus sie sagen netz sehr
nahe die meisten die an die macht kommen
sind natürlich weiße männer denken wir
an marie le pen würden sie sagen na ja
das ist ein ganzes eine ganz andere
kategorie
die reiht sich doch eigentlich auch in
diese reihe ein und sie ist eine frau
absolut auf jeden fall
es ist unsinn zu denken eine frau könne
nicht einer faschistischen oder weit
rechts angesiedelten bewegung angehören
das kommt von einem vorurteil den sie
sicher auch schon begegnet sind
sie diskutieren mit jemandem zum
beispiel über sexismus oder frauenrechte
und dieser sagt aber ich bin mit einer
frau befreundet und sie ist nicht ihre
meinung als müsste jede frau in diesen
dingen gleich denken als wären wir durch
eine schwarmintelligenz oder ein
die magische schwarm vagina miteinander
verbunden doch diese rechten bewegungen
sind sexistisch denn ihre anhänger
leiden unter verletztem männlichem stolz
und zu ihrem rassistischen und
nationalistischen gedankengut gehört
auch die rückkehr zu traditionellen
patriarchalischen werten
obwohl sie natürlich nicht von pappe hat
reden sondern von familie als gäbe es
nur eine einzige richtige form von
familie
sie wollen die rechte der frauen am
arbeitsplatz einschränken sind gegen die
legalisierung der abtreibung und sogar
gegen das recht auf verhütung an diese
diese männer fühlen sich durch frauen
farbige und immigranten um ihr
natürliches recht betrogen herrschen der
positionen in der gesellschaft zu
bekleiden und entsprechend respektiert
zu werden und das ist nicht in ordnung
wie kommen sie eigentlich selber zum
zynismus
ich wurde feministin als ich noch sehr
jung war zufällig lass ich das buch die
ganze frau von germaine greer
damals hatten wir noch nicht den
gleichen zugang zum internet wie heute
und ich meinte ich sei die einzige die
so dachte ich schrieb german trier sogar
einen brief und sie antwortete mir was
wirklich toll daran ist kürzlich wurde
das archiv von germaine race werk in
australien geordnet und dabei stießen
sie auf einen brief in dem ich geh ja
als zwölfjähriger mit meiner schönsten
schrift geschrieben hatte ich will auch
feministin sein mich ob sie den brief
verwenden dürften und ich sagte
natürlich das ist toll es ist ein stück
meiner persönlichen geschichte in
gewisser hinsicht bin ich etwas
ungewöhnlich viele kommen durch eigene
erfahrungen zum feminismus oder weil sie
aktivist innen kennenlernen und sich für
ihre ideen interessieren das ist
großartig
doch ich las feministische theorien als
ich noch sehr klein war von rias büchern
bin ich lieber zu den schriften anderer
feministinnen
ich las als kind viele bücher statt
milch mit der welt zu befassen die mich
umgab
meine kindheit in bücher so war ich und
so kam ich zum feminismus
das ist keine alltägliche erfahrung doch
ich will damit nicht sagen ich wurde für
minister in bevor ich cool war auf die
bücher kommen wir später noch zu
sprechen auch auf die bedeutung der
geschichten für sie lassen sie uns auch
beim termin ist es bleiben der für sie
wichtig ist sie sagen ja ganz klar zum
beispiel in ihrem buch und sagt bahre
dinge wir brauchen eine meuterei wir
brauchen eine revolution was ist das
ziel ihrer feministischen revolution von
dem sie träumen oder die sie auch kommen
sehen
sehen sie niemand hat das recht zu
bestimmen wie die welt für alle anderen
sein sollte
davon bin ich immer mehr überzeugt wenn
ich sehe wie extremisten und vertreter
weit rechts politisierende bewegungen
anderen ihre sicht der zukunft zu
drängen versucht aber ich möchte in
einer welt leben in der frauen in erster
linie als menschen behandelt werden
in einer welt in der frauen das recht
haben zu entscheiden was mit ihrem
eigenen körper geschieht in einer welt
in der frauen zusätzlich zu ihrer
täglichen arbeit nicht auch noch gefühls
arbeit leisten müssen
in einer welt in der wir anders denken
über die bedeutung der arbeit in der wir
uns fragen was gleichberechtigung heißt
und welche rolle unsere identität in
unserem alltag spielt - muss der mich
interessiert kann nicht vom anti
rassismus und von der lgbt bewegung
getrennt werden
da geht es um sehr ähnliche anliegen das
wusste ich noch nicht als ich mit zwölf
oder dreizehn feministische bücher las
ich bin mit der zeit hinein gewachsen
als ich meine politische überzeugung
entwickelte und ich gleichgesinnte in
der realen welt kennen lernte sie haben
es die npd bewegungen mehrere male
erwähnt vielleicht müssen das ganz kurz
erklären also lässt wie in trance
menschen also die das ganze sammelbecken
man spricht ja manchmal auch von den
queer start ich sie selber auch
vielleicht können wir diesen begriff
auch noch ganz kurz hinzunehmen sie
sagen eigentlich ist der feminismus
heute eine erwägung die das gesamte
spektrum der queen
auch objekt worum genau geht es denn
wenn die leute von queer studies
sprechen ist das eine forschungsrichtung
die sexuelle identitäten untersucht doch
wenn jemand sagt er seit 4
kann er alles sein was mit diesen
buchstaben kürzen bezeichnet wird und
nicht heterosexuell ist oder c6 will was
das gegenteil von transsexuell bedeutet
wer ist ein sammelbegriff für
homosexuelle lesben bisexuelle
transgender oder menschen die nicht
geschlechts konform sind und sich wieder
als männlich noch weiblich sagt viel
mehr aus als mit wem man ins bett geht
es drückt aus wie man sein leben lebt
und wer man ist die gemeinschaft aus der
ich komme und in der ich einen großteil
meiner jugend verbrachte ist eine queere
community daher stammen viele meiner
politischen überzeugungen haben sie
gesagt sie wollen keinen begriff von
feminismus definieren und sagen das ist
feminismus und das andere nicht trotzdem
kommen sie ja mit einem begriff der sehr
breit ist dass sie sagen selber da
gehört da zb auch dazu nicht rassistisch
zu sein
würden sie dann sagen die firmen
aktivistin hatte recht die eine
wahlkampfveranstaltung von meinen lippen
gestört hat und gesagt hat sie ist
keines ist eine effektive feministin
kann man im moment keine feministin
seien per definitionem wurde ich sagt
sie sich seit der minister
na ja sie hat sich in gewissen in
gewisser hinsicht natürlich schon auch
gesagt sie möchte dafür einstehen dass
zb frauen gleiche löhne oder solche
dinge erhalten also für gleiche rechte
der frauen würde sie wahrscheinlich
schon eintreten
aber das reicht ihnen nicht ich würde
sagen wer lohngleichheit für frauen
fordert ist nicht automatisch
feministinnen höchstens ein vernünftiger
mensch leider zeigen viele von marin
lippe ins politischen überzeugungen dass
sie kein vernünftiger mensch ist keine
identität
sie können sich nicht einfach als er
minister in bezeichnen und schon sind
sie
feminismus zeigt sich im handel wie sie
für andere frauen für mädchen und
unterdrückte menschen einstehen
marie le pen tut das nicht daher habe
ich mit ihrem feminismus ein problem
aber ich sage oft dass es viele
verschiedene arten von feminismus club
einige davon sind ganz einfach falsch
doch anstatt sich darüber zu streiten
was feminismus ist und sich aufzuregen
dass jeder und jeder etwas anderes
darunter versteht sollten wir
entscheiden was am nützlichsten ist und
was er als erstes angehen müssen und
natürlich völlig recht die gegner und
gegnerinnen des feminismus aber niemand
freude daran wenn sie die feministinnen
sozusagen auseinander treiben können und
aufzeigen dass die sich am total
widersprechen wenn ich trotzdem habe ich
ein punkt noch ein bisschen bleiben dann
geht es mir viel mehr darum noch besser
zu verstehen worum es ihnen genau geht
und ein punkt der mich interessiert ist
dass sie an einer gewissen stelle ich
weiß nicht ob sie das immer noch so
sagen würden sagen sie der feminismus
muss auch anti kapitalistisch seien
würden sie das so unterschrieben
auf jeden fall könnte es dann der
feminismus der mich am meisten
interessiert gründet auf der ökonomie
denn für mich liegt der ursprung der
unterdrückung von frauen in ihrer
ökonomischen unterdrückung mehr geht es
aber nicht nur um lohngleichheit oder
unser recht die gleiche arbeit wie
männer verrichten zu dürfen
es geht darum dass ein großer teil der
arbeit in der gesellschaft nicht oder
sehr schlecht bezahlt ist und meist von
frauen verrichtet wird
ich meine damit das gewähren von
kinderbetreuung und hausarbeit putzen
cleaning weil die dinge die wir oft gar
nicht als richtige arbeit betrachten und
die doch überlebenswichtig sind für das
funktionieren der gesellschaft an sommer
auf weibliche und sexuelle unterdrückung
haben ihren ursprung oft in einer
gesellschaftlichen struktur welche die
frauen dazu drängt diese arbeiten gratis
zu verrichten
und ich denke das muss sich ändern und
zwar nicht nur auf der ebene der
gesetzgebung
wir müssen vielmehr unsere haltung
gegenüber der arbeit verrichten
und sie mehr respektieren auf
individueller wie auf gemeinschaftlicher
ebene
diese arbeit anerkennen könnte doch aber
auch möglich sein in einem
kapitalistischen system nun jeden arbeit
kann ins kapitalistische system
integriert werden
aber die idee der arbeit ist nicht
unbedingt kapitalistisch in den 70er und
80er jahren gab es eine wichtige
bewegung mit dem slogan lohn gegen
hausarbeit
damit wollten die aktivistinnen
klarmachen dass hausarbeit und die
erziehung der kinder seriöse arbeit ist
und damit gleichwertig mit dem was als
richtige berufsarbeit gilt und mehr von
männern verrichtet wird jeweils diese
frauen damals forderten ist immer noch
aktuell
genau ich wollte nur ihre these
aufnehmen dass der meniskus
antikapitalistisch sein müssen wollte
nur darauf hinweisen wir könnten ja uns
ausdenken das eben die entsprechende
hausarbeit bitte bezahlt wird auch dass
man sich beispielsweise in lebensläufen
ausweisung kann dass man sehr lange
familienarbeit gemacht habt männer wie
frauen dass das mitzählen würde aber das
würde noch nicht gegen den kapitalismus
sprechen oder was genau ist die
speerspitze die sie da einwerfen
ich denke wir einen anständigen lohn für
geleistete arbeit erwartet stellt keine
antikapitalistische sondern eine
sozialistische forderung die am
kapitalismus beanstande ich die
ausbeuterischen bedingungen für
arbeitnehmer und die gewinne die leute
mit ihrem kapital und ihrem besitz
machen ich glaube dass anti kapitalismus
nicht von feminismus getrennt werden
kann
natürlich gibt es feministische
strömungen die nicht anti kapitalistisch
sind es gibt alle möglichen formen von
feminismus und alle haben ihre
berechtigung
die eine nützliche die anderen weniger
so können wir ein beispiel reinnehmen zb
sheryl sandberg ceo von facebook mit
ihrem buch wien in einem see minister
manifest sie sagt frauen es geht darum
dass sie auch endlich euren teilnimmt
und dass sie auch an die spitze der
macht kommt auch semin ismus
natürlich ist das meniskus aber eine
ziemlich sinnlose form denn davon
profitiert nur eine sehr begrenzte zahl
von frauen die bereits sehr gut bezahlte
stellen haben und an der spitze ihrer
karriere stehen
jobs hat meistens sind sie heterosexuell
leben in einem westlichen land und
stellen mit ihrem feminismus das
patriarchalische und kapitalistische
system nicht groß in frage es ist ein
feminismus der nebenbei betrieben werden
kann und das problem nicht benennt der
plan er geht davon aus dass frauen nur
mehr verantwortung übernehmen und
aktiver sein müssen oder abgebaut
mehr schmiden wird dabei die männliche
gewalt gegen frauen die lohnungleichheit
und die systematische unterdrückung von
frauen die immer noch sehr verbreitet
ist
es gibt viele feministinnen die mit
ihrem engagement in erster linie die
männer nicht verärgern wollen
das verstehe ich denn wir werden von
früher kindheit dazu erzogen das mädchen
schlimme dinge erleben wenn sie jungs
und männer verärgern
deshalb verstehe ich warum frauen solche
strategien anwenden
aber das ist nicht meine politik sie
wehren sich auch gegen die vorstellung
dass diese frauen sagen können wir
machen jetzt karriere wir kommen durch
die gläserne decke hindurch und dann
wird sozusagen die gleichstellung runter
sie kann sie sagen das funktioniert
nicht meine damen sind natürlich
funktioniert das nicht
die trickle down theorie sagt wenn es
den reichsten gut geht sie kann das geld
und die chancen irgendwie in die unteren
gesellschaftsschichten durch doch vor
allem die letzten zehn jahre haben
bewiesen dass das überhaupt nicht stimmt
je reicher die reichen werden desto mehr
bleiben die menschen zurück die ganz
unten sind ähnlich ist es mit dem
feminismus und der befreiung der frauen
[Musik]
natürlich ist es gut wenn frauen
karriere machen und den sprung nach oben
schaffen dazu ermutige ich sie aber ich
denke nicht nur das ist wichtig es geht
vielmehr darum das leben der frauen in
allen gesellschaftsschichten zu
verbessern
in den usa sind zum beispiel die meisten
schlecht bezahlten angestellten frauen
davon viele farbige ihnen hilft es nicht
wenn mehr frauen in aufsichtsräten
sitzen
eine gefahr die bestehen könnte die ich
interessant finde ist die sache mal ganz
platt die solidaritätswelle dass man von
frauen erwartet dass sie sich immer
darum kümmern sich zu überlegen was
macht das system mit denjenigen die
sozusagen am untersten punkt stehen also
sagen ja auch der feminismus der muss
breiter gedacht werden der muss eben
nicht nur die weiße vermögende
heterosexuelle frau beachten die
karriere machen kann sondern muss auch
die ganze armada von nannys von
putzfrauen und so weiter mit beachten
die solidaritätswelle nein so etwas wie
weil die frauen dann diejenigen sind die
auch noch rücksicht nehmen schaffen die
es erst recht nicht währenddessen die
mir noch keine rücksicht nehmen
gibt es so etwas wie eine
solidaritätsfahrt ich verstehe nicht
genau was sie unter solidarität falle
verstehen ich kenne keine bewegungen der
solidarität eine falle darstellt nicht
nur frauen sollten bewegungen gründen um
die welt zu verändern damit das leben
für alle und nicht nur für die reichen
besser wird ich denke dafür sollten sich
alle einsetzen
deshalb war ich jahrelang in
sozialistischen und antikapitalistischen
bewegungen auf der ganzen welt aktiv und
engagierte mich in occupy wallstreet und
anderen occupy bewegungen mit dem motto
wir sind die 99 prozent
und ich denke solidarität ist in diesen
bewegungen alles andere als eine
zerstörerische kraft und konkretes
beispiel zu machen
ich erlebe sehr oft dass man von frauen
sehr viel mehr wie von männern erwartet
dass sie zb veranstaltungen gleichmäßig
mit frauen und männern besetzten dass
sie stellen und frauen vergeben dass die
frauenförderung betreiben wenn frauen
die es nicht tun werden sie
viele forscher kritisiert als männer
gleichzeitig habe ich manchmal den
eindruck ich verstehe dieses anliegen
und tage selber extrem mit aber auf der
anderen seite müssen wir frauen dann
immer den doppelten aufwand betreiben
weil wir sind diejenigen die sich immer
darum kümmern müssen dass frauen auch
zum zug kommen
schauen sie ich denke es ist nicht
schlecht dafür zu sorgen dass an einem
anlass gleich viele frauen teilnehmen
wie männer damit parität gewährleistet
ist wenn sie sagen das sei den männern
egal und nur frauen würden sich darum
bemühen ist das nicht das problem der
frauen sondern eher männer
anstatt zu sagen solche feministischen
ansprüche seien übertrieben
sollten wir die männer in die pflicht
nehmen ich persönlich kenne viele männer
die unter druck kommen und deshalb sagen
ich beteilige mich nicht an einem
podiumsgespräch zudem nur männer
eingeladen wurden ich nehme nicht an
einem anlass teil der nur männer zu wort
kommen lässt
wir müssen männer dazu bringen
diesbezüglich verantwortung zu
übernehmen anstatt alle bemühungen den
frauen zu überlassen
das kann ich unterschreiben
ich würde gerne mit ihnen über den
körper sprechen der körper ist sozusagen
im zentrum des feminismus schon immer
gewesen wir können simon dem oval lesen
wir können die butler lesen es dreht
sich immer alles um den körper
warum diese fixierung auf den körper ich
frage mich manchmal ist es irgendwie
nicht möglich mal über die gedanken
primär von frauen zu reden oder sind die
zu wenig interessant warum reden wir
immer wieder über den körper broder so
werden wir auf der ganzen welt behandelt
wir sind zuerst einmal körper und keine
denkende wesen viele feministinnen sind
so besorgt um den weiblichen körper weil
er ein arbeitsinstrument ist und an ihm
die unterdrückung der frau sichtbar wird
eine der wichtigsten arbeiten in einer
gesellschaft ist das kinderkriegen und
wenn man durch abschreibungs verbote und
einschränkungen der gesundheitsvorsorge
versucht die frauen über ihren körper zu
kontrollieren
kontrolliert man die reproduktions
mittel
wie gewisse feministinnen den weiblichen
körper in anlehnung an die
produktionsmittel bezeichnen die
politischen forderungen von frauen und
feministinnen sind nicht auf den körper
fixiert
das ist der falsche ausdruck kommt wir
kommen auf den körper zurück weil hier
die unterdrückung beginnt nicht nur aber
vor allem für die frauenbewegung ist der
weibliche körper zentral weil an ihm
gewalt und unterdrückung erlebt wird
ich denke deshalb es ist überhaupt nicht
falsch oder ungerechtfertigt auf den
körper zu fokussieren
gesunde motto ich würde gerne auf die
ganze frage der reproduktion später noch
zu sprechen kommen nun noch kurz beim
beim körper und bei den körperbildern
bleiben unsere kultur ist ja besessen
davon vorzugeben wie der weibliche
körper auszusehen hat natürlich gibt es
auch vorgaben für den männlichen körper
mehr und mehr aber bei den frauen ist es
viel extremer ich frage mich manchmal
warum ist es zum beispiel so dass in der
maske völlig klar für die frauen immer
mindestens doppelt so viele zeit
einberechnet wird auch für männer müssen
wir irgendwie uns mehr verschönere dass
partner bekommen es ist teil einer
kultur die den weiblichen körper in
seinem alltäglichen zustand für nicht
akzeptabel hält
in unserer kultur wird von den frauen
viel mehr aufwand für aussehen und
aufmachung erwartet der grund dafür ist
kontrolle
man kontrolliert wie sich frauen
verhalten und präsentieren
man kontrolliert sie ihren körper wer
den körper von menschen kontrolliert
kontrolliert ihr leben das ist eine form
von propaganda und indoktrination die
sehr früh in unserem leben beginnt ich
bin oft frustriert wenn mir jemand sagt
frauen lieben es doch sich zu schminken
modisch zu kleiden und shoppen zu gehen
ich mag tatsächlich kleider und make ups
ich ließ mich vorhin in der maske
geschminkt
aber wenn sie sich dazu gezwungen fühlen
und den eindruck haben sonst an der
arbeit oder in der öffentlichkeit nicht
akzeptiert zu werden wird es zum problem
zum druck wie wissen wir genau was
frauen wirklich wollen sie beschreiben
in ihrem buch sehr schön eine junge frau
die in einem vortrag sitzt und die zu
ihnen sagt wie soll ich wissen was ich
wirklich will
also manchmal wir sind ja alle sehr
umgeben von werbung man mal wissen ja
gar nicht so recht möchten wir wirklich
so aussehen oder ist das sozusagen das
einzige vorbild das sie haben das ist
eine sehr wichtige frage kommt manchmal
oft sind menschen verwirrt und wissen
nicht was sie wirklich möchten die
wünsche der menschen werden beeinflusst
von der werbung und verriet namen vom
druck der familie und der gesellschaft
mit meinen feministischen büchern
versuche ich wie viele aktivistinnen
auch den frauen zu vermitteln
es gibt andere dinge die er womöglich
wollte es gibt andere optionen die auf
euch warten ihr müsst also nicht nur
alles daransetzen schön auszusehen den
perfekten mann zu heiraten kinder zu
kriegen und einen gut bezahlten aber
nicht ganz so lukrativen job heuermann
zu haben
es geht andere wege und möglichkeiten
ein gutes erfülltes leben zu haben
darum geht es in meinem werk
ich versuche den frauen zu sagen dass
andere lebensentwürfe möglich sind man
geht aber auch auf fahrten sie müssen
über gesetze sprechen oder über
wirkliche rahmenbedingungen in einer
gesellschaft und da ist beispielsweise
die prostitution immer ein thema aber
das diskutiert wird ist prostitution
etwas was frauen freiwillig
selbstbestimmt tun können sie sind ja
klarerweise gegen ein
prostitutionsverbot jetzt ja ich bin
dagegen unter anderem kenne ich viele
sexarbeiterinnen die auch gegen ein
prostitutionsverbot sind weil sie angst
haben dass ihre arbeit und ihr leben
dadurch zusätzlich erschwert würden sie
haben bereits einen schwierigen
stigmatisierten job und können keine
polizei brauchen
ob nun frauen und natürlich sind es
nicht nur frauen
ob menschen sexarbeit aus freiem willen
verrichten ist irgendwie die falsche
frage wer hat denn schon seinen job
freiwillig gewählt sie und ich
ich habe eine erfüllende arbeit aber
viele menschen lieben ihren job nicht
wirklich die meisten würden wenn sie die
wahl hätten ihre arbeit nicht behalten
und wir zeigen mit dem finger auf
sexarbeit weil wir sie für unmoralische
halten als alle anderen jobs wir haben
den eindruck frauen die mit ihren körper
auf diese weise geld verdienen sein
unmoralisch aber es geht nicht darum ob
man seinen job frei wählen kann
es geht um die natur der arbeit anstatt
sexarbeit sollten wir alle bezahlte
arbeit verbieten und allen ein gleiches
grundeinkommen geben
aber das würde für sie heißen sex arbeit
ist kann genauso wie beispielsweise
arbeit in einem kaufhaus oder arbeit in
einer bank ausbeuterisch sein oder gegen
das selbstbestimmungsrecht einer person
hat sie ganz klar jede art von arbeit
kann ausbeuterisch seien vor allem für
frauen
dass wir gesagt haben erwartet man oft
von ihnen dass sie ihre sexuellen
attribute am arbeitsplatz
hervorstreichen ich denke nicht dass
irgendeiner form von arbeit moralisch
weniger richtig wäre als eine andere
solange keine menschen dabei verletzt
werden da sind wir eigentlich wieder
beim anti kapitalismus oder den wir am
anfang hatten ihre politische theorie
die mit dem feminismus verknüpft wird ja
ganz genau
männer und frauen verrichten solche
arbeit nicht weil sie es unbedingt
wollen sondern weil sie keine andere
wahl haben
weil sie sonst sich und ihre familie
nicht über die runden bringen
es geht also tatsächlich menschen die
sich zur sexarbeit gezwungen sind
die einen tun es weil es einfacher ist
damit geld zu verdienen als mit anderen
jobs aber sie sind dazu gezwungen mit
weil kapitalismus und realismus hans in
hand gehen und deshalb gehören anti
kapitalismus und feminismus für mich
zusammen ich würde trotzdem noch kurz
beim bei der prostitution bleiben weil
ich einfach von den debatten her weiß
dass viele menschen entschuldigen sie
können wir von sexarbeit sprechen
die aktivisten ziehen diesen begriff
jenem der prostitution vor rost ich
lasse mich gerne darauf ein
also sprechen wir noch einmal über die
sexarbeit weil der punkt ist ja ein
bisschen dass viele leute glauben mit
dem körper in dieser art und weise zu
arbeiten ist eine andere dimension
eine person die das sehr stark vertreten
ist alice schwarzer auch eine der großen
semin ist ihnen das auch an diesem tisch
ihr und ich habe sie gefragt ob es nicht
möglich sei einvernehmlich gegen geld
sex zu haben und wir schauen uns ganz
kurz gemeinsam ihre antwort an die
toleranz oder gar akzeptanz und
förderung von prostitution dieses
problem haben wir ja heute in unseren
ländern ist ein skandal weil sie
akzeptiert dass man den menschen zur
ware macht und sexualität ist keine ware
und was heißt denn einvernehmlich wissen
sie wenn ein mann bezahlt dafür eine
frau dass er sie penetrieren kann sie
anfassen kann sie benutzen kann
da kann man von einvernehmlichkeit keine
regel sein und sie sind sehr war eine
frau können sich vorstellen ich meine
denke das einfach mal zu ende
dass sie sagen für 50 euro oder 30
manchmal sogar zählen je nachdem wie
dringlich das ist und woher sie kommen
und wo sie stehen kann es losgehen
das ist doch klar dass es ein skandal
ist ich bin überhaupt nicht ihre meinung
erst einmal sagt sie die prostitution
wie sie es nennt mache aus den menschen
aus ihren körpern kommerzielle objekte
von sexarbeit ist sich die einzige form
von arbeit die das tut fast jede arbeit
in unserer gesellschaft degradiert den
körper zu einem kommerziellen objekt zb
die dienstleistungsbranche oder das
reinigungs wesen wenn wir es wirklich
skandalös finden dass menschen dinge
gegen ihren willen tun müssen
sollten wir eine soziale revolution
lancieren mit alice schwarzer an der
spitze um den kapitalismus zu zerstören
aber ich glaube so denkt sie nicht sie
greift nur die sexarbeit an
wenn wir hingegen sagen jemand sind
dafür zu bezahlen dass er etwas tut was
er sonst nicht tun würde sei keine
einvernehmliche handlung dann bin ich
einverstanden
das ist eine andere art von konsens aber
so ergeht es auch menschen die in läden
arbeiten oder taxi fahren und auch ihre
freiheit zählt bin ich feministin und
antikapitalistischer alt - aber ich
kenne menschen die sich aus freiem
willen 46 arbeit entschieden haben
wenn sie arbeiten müssen ziehen sie
diese arbeit einem anderen job vor
ich kenne leute die gut wird und leute
die schlechte erfahrungen mit sex arbeit
gemacht haben und ziemlich gibt es da
eine skala
ich finde es falsch zu sagen dass
sexarbeit per se ausbeuterisch ist ich
denke das ist ein moralisches urteil und
beruht auf der idee wir frauen dürften
nicht einfach so sex haben
einzig innerhalb der ehe mit einem mann
ich finde ihre argumentation interessant
weil sie nicht wie andere feministinnen
sagen es geht darum dass eine frau
selber entscheiden kann und soll was sie
mit ihrem körper macht wie im übrigen
auch jedermann der körper gehört mir ich
entscheide selber was ich damit machen
sondern sie drehen sozusagen und sagen
es geht durchaus um einwilligung und
konzert aber das betrifft die ganze
phalanx der verschiedenen arbeiten die
wir machen wenn ihr bei diesem argument
bleiben und sagen okay der dreh und
angelpunkt ist die zustimmung wie müsste
denn eine gesellschaft funktionieren in
der jeder das machen kann wozu er
zustimmt in dieser form wie sie
zustimmung definieren
das wäre sehr interessant nicht wahr
ich hätte gern eine gesellschaft die
mehr auf dem prinzip des einvernehmens
basiert von oben bis nach unten
ich denke das prinzip von konsens von
einer kultur in der gegenseitiges
einverständnis herrscht kommt aus der
feministischen bewegung aus der anti
vergewaltigungs bewegung
aber eigentlich ist es auf das leben so
vieler
schon anwendbar eine der ideen die in
letzter zeit sie auf zustimmung stieß
ist das basis einkommen für alle darüber
habt ihr hier kürzlich abgestimmt da
gilt es auch um konsens so bartmann
beträgt damit dass menschen nicht arbeit
verrichten müssen die sie erniedrigen
und entwürdigend finden dass menschen
mehr wahlmöglichkeiten haben und sich
freiwillig für etwas entscheiden können
anstatt sich dazu gezwungen zu sehen das
ist die wurzel eines politischen
handelns und deswegen bin ich für
ministern und gleichzeitig
antikapitalisten viele sagen imperial
funktioniert das nicht es würde sich nie
finanzieren lassen auf machen sie mit
solchen in tierischen vorwissen
es gibt viele möglichkeiten ein basis
einkommen zu finanzieren weltweit was
man immer mehr experimente in diesem
bereich viele menschen auf der ganzen
welt versuchen nicht nur herauszufinden
ob es möglich ist sondern wie es
umgesetzt werden kann
denn die natur der arbeit verändert sich
die leute realisieren dass immer mehr
arbeiten automatisiert werden und viele
traditionelle jobs verschwinden
wir müssen ziemlich schnell herausfinden
wie wir es schaffen den meisten menschen
ein anständiges leben zu ermöglichen
ohne dass er dafür bezahlte arbeit
leisten müssen haben sie völlig recht
möglicherweise ist es gar nicht mehr so
dass wir nur oder wegen ideologischer
gründe für ein grundeinkommen ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
argumentieren sondern weil die
digitalisierung uns dazu zwingt
irgendwelche abfederung mechanismen zu
entwickeln für die knappheit der jobs
das sagen zum beispiel auch bruno sonnen
gaddafi vom mrt da stimme ich ihnen sie
dazu was ich sehr interessant finde ist
dass sie sich ja auch viele gedanken
darüber machen wo haben wir den hebel
wirkung und wo können wir diese
revolution wenn wir's mal so nennen
würden wirklich vorantreiben und etwas
was mir gefällt ist dass sie auch so
etwas sagen die dort da jetzt also mach
keine diäten begehre auf sie weisen zum
beispiel darauf hin dass alleine die
kaufkraft die wir frauen haben die welt
verändern könnten frauen geben ungefähr
14 ihres einkommens offenbar aus für
kosmetikprodukte für diätprodukte also
wenn wir aufhören würden diese produkte
zu kaufen würde die welt anders aussehen
sie würde anders aussehen ein wenig
zumindest so viele branchen hängen davon
ab dass den frauen vorgeschrieben wird
wie sie aussehen müssen
ich bin angetan von make-up schönheit
und mode
es macht spaß mich schön zu machen aber
ich habe viele freiheiten in meinem
leben ich kann nicht alles aber sehr
vieles frei wählen
einer der gründe hier über geld zu
sprechen ist die wichtige frage was
würden frauen sonst mit ihrem geld
machen
ich bin antikapitalisten aber ich finde
es wichtig über geld und über die
unabhängigkeit und freiheit der menschen
zu sprechen
rechnet man zusammen wie viele frauen
über die letzten zehn jahre für kleider
schuhe und make-up ausgegeben haben muss
man davon ausgehen dass sich viele dazu
gedrängt fühlten und ohne druck ganz
anders entschieden hätten
wenn man also eine kultur fördert die
frauen dazu bringt all das zeugs zu
kaufen unterstützt man auch eine gewisse
finanzielle ungleichheit
jetzt sind wir wieder bei forstinger so
bei der bei beim zwang und vorhin haben
wir über den content gesprochen die
einwilligung ich komme noch einmal mit
dieser frage mich selber aus umtreibt
wie finden sie heraus was frauen
freiwillig tun also wann genau willigen
frauen den einzug so viele schuhe zu
kaufen und wann genau ist es zwar das
ist eine wirklich interessante frage
ich glaube nicht dass es eine klare
linie gibt und man sagen kann diese
person ist völlig frei und diese
überhaupt nicht denke ich denke das
verhalten der meisten menschen ist
geprägt von einer mischung aus freiheit
und unfreiheit und es geht um eine
änderung der kultur
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel niemand in
unserer westlichen welt ich kenne
jedenfalls niemanden
ist gesetzlich dazu gezwungen diät zu
halten die haare wachsen zu lassen oder
geld für make-up und kosmetische
chirurgie auszugehen
die leute tun das weil man ihnen von
klein auf beigebracht hat das sie sonst
nicht wertvoll oder liebenswert sind und
allein und einsam sein werden ist eine
art von zwang und nötigung die man in
missbräuchlichen beziehungen beobachtet
denn man kann leute dazu bringen dinge
zu tun indem man ihnen mit gewalt oder
gefängnistrakt doch wenn man menschen
massiv schikanieren will ist es sehr
viel wirkungsvoller zu sagen wenn du das
oder das nicht tust bist du nicht
liebenswert oder was einsam da ist diese
angst haben viele frauen schon in frühen
jahren entwickelt weil man es uns
bereits in der kindheit beigebracht hat
glauben sie die situation hat sich
irgendwie verbessert also wir können ja
sehen frauen haben möglicherweise mehr
rechte aus früher sie sind stärker
gleichgestellt das ist mit sicherheit
der fall wenn jetzt vergleich mit dem 19
jahrhundert oder so aber das
schönheitsideal der frau ist vielleicht
faust extremer geworden ist ja ganz klar
das schönheitsideal wurde in den letzten
zwanzig bis dreißig jahren immer mehr
zum zwang jeweils erste 1991 in ihrem
buch der mythos schönheit über die
zunahme von schönheits standards welche
die frauen kontrollieren und verhindern
dass sie zu selbstbewusst werden und das
ist nicht unbedingt eine große
verschwörung sondern vielmehr eine
willkommene erscheinung die das
patriarchat und den kapitalismus am
leben erhalten akkus natürlich haben wir
fortschritte gemacht seit dem
neunzehnten oder dem vierzehnten
jahrhundert das heißt aber nicht dass
wir alles erreicht haben oder nicht
manchmal wieder zurückgehen
kurz in der viktorianischen zeit gab es
zb einen massiven rückschritt in bezug
auf die weibliche rolle in der
gesellschaft
wir haben diese vorstellung der soziale
fortschritt gehe immer weiter
doch die heutige situation zeigt etwas
anderes
und das bringt uns zurück zur donald
trump und den protesten gegen ihn
alles weist darauf hin dass es in den
nächsten jahren für frauen schlimmer
wird wir können uns nicht zurücklehnen
und selbstzufrieden sagen wir haben
alles erreicht
es gibt noch sehr viel mehr zu tun ich
hatte mich darauf eingestellt mich mit
hillary clinton herumzuschlagen darüber
zu diskutieren ob sie wirklich
feministin ist und auf diesem niveau
mehr veränderungen einzufordern
stattdessen müssen wir nun wieder unsere
grundrechte verteidigen und das ist kein
ermutigendes zeichen
obwohl so viele menschen protestieren
der feminismus im alltag oder in der
politik hat sich mit kleinen feinen
unterschieden zu befassen muss sich
überlegen welche strategien hilfreich
sind es gibt aber auch die großen bogen
sie sind eine person die sagen die
großen politischen schlachten wurden
meistens in der fantasie geschlagen
geschichten sind wichtig wir müssen
wieder lernen unsere utopien hinzugeben
geschichten auszudenken
sie schreiben ja auch science fiction
geschichten erzählen sie ja warum ist
science fiction so wichtig man kann
herausfinden wie privilegiert menschen
gesellschaftlich sind indem man sie
fragt in welcher epoche sie gerne leben
würden wenn sie zeitreisende wären zum
beispiel möchten fast keine menschen die
farbig weiblich oder queer sind in die
vergangenheit zurückkehren
denn früher waren die lebensbedingungen
viel schlimmer für alle die nicht weiß
und männlich waren und genügend geld hat
ich denke geschichten über mögliche
zukunftsszenarien zu schreiben und zu
erzählen ist sehr wichtig vor allem
heute weil die menschen die zukunft sehr
düster sehen und sich keine welt
vorstellen können in der es sich leben
lässt oder die sogar besser ist
ich bin nicht an utopien interessiert
sondern an verschiedenen versionen
unserer zukunft deswegen finde ich es so
wichtig im kulturellen bereich zu
arbeiten und geschichten zu erzählen von
unterschiedlichen menschen mit
unterschiedlichen lebensformen
geschichten in den
es nicht nur eine art von heldentum gibt
all das ist sehr politisch und wichtig
für mich ich bin zudem ein werk deshalb
liebe hier das finde ich jetzt sehr
interessant dass sie sagen niemand von
der lgt bewegung ist eigentlich klar
aber ich habe es mir noch nie so klar
gemacht würde davon denken oder davon
träumen zurück gehen zu wollen aber es
gibt natürlich ganz viele leute und
gerade diejenigen leute sind diejenigen
auch von denen wir als verlierer und
sprechen die eben populistische
bewegungen befeuern die sich er wieder
zurück sehen also vielleicht ist
tatsächlich gibt es im moment eine
verschränkung diejenigen die sich auf
die zukunft freuen und diejenigen die
gerne zurück möchten auf jeden fall die
bestrebungen der neuen rechten und von
rechtsaußen gruppierungen sind rückwärts
gerichtet macht amerika wieder groß die
fordern sie in den usa oder bringt uns
unser land zurück in großbritannien als
würden sie am liebsten in einer
kollektiven zeitreise in die 19 60er
oder 70er jahre oder noch weiter zurück
versetzt
sie haben nicht die geringste idee wie
sie zu einer besseren zukunft beitragen
können
sie vertreten menschen die sich nur
zurückwünschen was sie verloren haben
lost
doch es gibt heute milliarden menschen
auf der welt die immer noch daran
glauben dass die hoffnung in der zukunft
und nicht in der vergangenheit liegt die
zukunft muss besser sein
und auch wenn wir das nicht sofort
erreichen müssen wir daran glauben dass
es möglich ist in ihren science fiction
geschichten geht es unter anderem auch
wieder um den weiblichen körper uns geht
zb auch darum dass eine person vorkommt
die ihr baby selber zusammen lötet
technisch gesehen also es geht auch um
die überwindung der der gebärmutter wenn
dir so wollen also biologie sagen sie
ist eine tragödie ist es tatsächlich
denken sie generell so oder was machen
sie mit frauen die sagen na ja aber ich
war sehr gerne schwanger
ich sage nicht es sei falsch schwanger
zu werden
ich habe viele freundinnen die schwanger
sind ich bin 30 jahre alt alle meine
bekannten bekommen momentan babys die
hälfte der schwangeren
schwärmen von mutter erde hören die
vögel zwitschern sehen blühend aus und
genießen ihrem zustand
die anderen müssen den ganzen tag
erbrechen und haben viele probleme und
schmerzen wieder ist es eine frage der
wahl
und natürlich ist mein experiment fiktiv
es handelt sich um science-fiction aber
es bringt viele aus der fassung
für sie ist es unvorstellbar dass frauen
ohne physische schwangerschaft ein kind
machen könnten
dabei haben feministinnen in den 1970 er
und 80 er jahren diese idee aufgebracht
das ist nichts neues
mich interessieren solche theorien aber
noch mehr interessiert mich warum die
leute so entfällt darauf reagieren
natürlich gibt es frauen die gerne
schlange sind aber auch für sie ist viel
arbeit damit verbunden und oft bekommen
sie nicht die unterstützung die sie
brauchen
die medizinische versorgung von frauen
wird immer noch zu wenig ernst genommen
ich finde das ist falsch und ungerecht
wir müssen uns ernsthaft dafür einsetzen
dass mehr zeit und geld für die
gesundheitsfürsorge von schwangeren
aufgewendet wird
wenn sie selber wählen könnten dem wie
immer haben sie hätten gerne kinder und
sie könnten herkömmlich eines haben oder
ist technisch fabrizieren was würden sie
wählen
ich hätte eindeutig lieber ein technisch
kompliziert das kind schauen sie mich an
wie ich gebraucht bin wäre ich anfangs
des 19 jahrhunderts bei der geburt
gestorben
so wie mich gott oder die natur
entworfen hat bin ich dazu bestimmt die
tragische erste frau von jemandem zu
sein
ich habe keine hoffnung das wurde nicht
gut ausgehen doch ernsthaft ich plane
nicht kinder zu haben
ich kann aber diesen wunsch sehr gut
verstehen viele meiner freundinnen sagen
ich möchte nicht unbedingt kinder aber
mein körper will schwanger werden
da sage ich nur nämlich auf die liste
trag ein baby für mich aus das klingt
toll gewisse frauen brauchen wohl diese
erfahrung eine andere sorte von
geschichte die sie schätzen ist die
serie
die beste titelmusik um was schätzen sie
an dieser serie so sehr die ja so
offenkundig gewalttätig blutrünstig und
zum teil auch sehr sexistisch ist ja
schon ein wenig warum sie gerade über
diese serie sprechen wollen
ich schreibe über viele verschiedene tv
serien und bücher aber ich finde herr
game of thrones sehr interessant weil
die serie so beliebt ist und sie gefällt
den leuten nicht nur wegen dem fing blut
den brüsten und drachen geschichte fühlt
sich vielmehr wie unser normales leben
an
denn es geht um eine gigantische
umweltkatastrophe und viele reiche leute
die etwas dagegen tun sollten
kempf vom grundlos gegeneinander mir
gefällt an dieser serie das niemand
richtige entscheidungen fällt die
vertreter der führenden klasse sind war
bayerische idioten und sie machen nichts
richtig es wird alles immer schlimmer
und wenn mal etwas positives passiert
ist es zufall
die handlung ist tatsächlich in vieler
hinsicht brutal und voller gewalt und es
gibt zahlreiche vergewaltigung
aber es kommen viele verschiedene
weibliche charaktertypen vor
und keine der frauen ist oberflächlich
ich habe nicht den eindruck dass die
serie sexistischer sei als andere
fantasy und science fiction filme ich
finde game of thrones wird zu unrecht
kritisiert so sitzt aber es ist schon
unter gefällt mir
es ist weder die beste noch die
schlechteste politische serie
aber wenn wir darüber sprechen was sie
sozusagen lesen wovon sie denken das
zeigt uns etwas urins mit der welt gehen
könnte und worauf wohin die auch gehen
sollen daneben science fiction die
möglichkeit ist sich auszudenken wie die
welt auch werden könnte dann erwähnen
sie in diesem kontext oft auch das buch
nach der braunen schatten von kathrin
burger king 1937 erschienen die
sozusagen den holocaust vorhergesagt hat
könnte man sagen gewisse stimmen
das was lesen sie denn im moment wovon
sie denken darin finde ich eigentlich
utopien oder disziplin wovon ich denke
so wie jetzt kommen die game of thrones
wird ja wohl nicht kommen
aber wo sind die zukunft schon nach
gepinselt oder vor gepinselt ich lese
nicht bücher die mir sagen wie die
zukunft sein wird diese bücher und mehr
verschiedene zukunftsszenarien
vorzustellen und auch einfach um mich zu
entspannen
aber ich lese so viele spannende science
fiction romane von frauen und farbigen
dass ich das ganze interview nord- davon
erzählen könnte es sind die teilnehmer
finden sie dürfen erst zwei seine platte
so gut
eines ist der interessante wo man die
macht von mary-jane mit der ich
befreundet bin
wir wurden freundinnen durch dieses buch
es geht darum dass plötzlich aus
irgendeinem grund alle weiblichen
teenager auf der welt die macht haben
menschen durch stromschläge zu töten
mit dieser simplen idee beginnt die
geschichte und man erfährt nach und nach
wie sich die welt dadurch verändert es
gibt ein happy end es geht darum wie
macht funktioniert ein anderer favorit
ist der roman die fünfte jahreszeit der
amerikanischen autorin katie in vieler
hinsicht ist er ähnlich wie die meisten
zukunfts oder endzeit roman aber mich
fasziniert dass das buch nicht darauf
fokussiert dass alles zusammenbricht
es geht vielmehr darum wie die menschen
vor allem die frauen denn die meisten
charaktere sind weiblich auf den
langsamen zerfall reagieren indem sie
sich zusammentun und gemeinschaften
bilden
denn in so vielen apokalyptischen
büchern ist erhält ein einsamer mann der
mit seinem ruf und seiner frau ums
überleben kämpft aber so funktionieren
gemeinschaften nicht in unserer
gesellschaft geht es nicht nur um
individualismus sondern auch um
gemeinschaft das gefällt mir an diesem
ich könnte noch viel mehr aufzählen ich
lese den ganzen tag sein
fiction ich bin ein totaler nach diesem
gespräch gleich wieder ab mit gleich
weiter lesen das heißt sie lieben es in
welten abzutauchen die vielleicht mit
der realität nur am rande zu tun haben
wenn es ums konkrete geht aber die
großen linien bleiben die gleichen es
geht um macht es geht um
gemeinschaftlich unterwegs was würden
sie sagen was braucht in unserer
gesellschaft im moment am dringendsten
wenn wir jetzt überlegen was müssen wir
anpacken ihr könnt nicht die große
utopie morgen starten
wovon was sind die kleinen schritte die
wir jetzt aus feministinnen unternehmen
sollten dort mein gott schauen sie ich
bin nur autorin letztendlich mache ich
keine politik es ist nicht meine aufgabe
zu sagen wie die welt sein sollte ich
denke das wäre arrogant aber zu den
dringlichsten aufgaben gehört es auf
einer breiten sozialen ebene dafür zu
sorgen dass die umwelt nicht vor die
hunde geht
dass die abwärtsspirale aufgehalten
werden kann
zudem sollten wir den aufschwung von
rechtsaußen bewegungen in der welt
stoppen und dafür sorgen dass alle
individuen möglichst frei und autonom
leben können
mit so viel handlungsspielraum wie
möglich doch offensichtlich ist die
klimaveränderung die größte
herausforderung für unsere spezies nur
können wir diese erst dann angehen wenn
wir alle möglichen kulturellen probleme
gelöst und unsere verkorkste und
kindische haltung zur wirtschaft
korrigiert haben
das wird hart sein aber das ist nochmals
eine ganz andere diskussion führen wir
diese diskussion ein anderes mal weiter
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich dass sie
hier waren logitech vielen nächste woche
spricht mein kollege yves bost mit dem
arzt und kabarettisten eckart von
hirschhausen über vermeintliche wunder
im alltag und über den aberglauben
sind sie manchmal abergläubisch dann
erzählen sie uns davon in einer mail an
philosophie srs punkt ch oder ich post
direkt auf facebook
und jetzt gleich gibt's in der
sternstunde kunst ganz großes kino denn
da heißt es
vorhang auf für die kritiker runde zum
schweizer filmpreis die auch über den
schweizer film die göttliche ordnung
diskutiert ein film der den kampf ums
frauenstimmrecht wieder aufleben lässt
danke fürs interesse ist bald und einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]